President Biden trying a midterms pivot
to save his party from a red wave
Wipeout a majority of Americans are in
total agreement that Joe doesn't have a
clue on what they care about
63 percent wish you would pay more
attention to key issues affecting their
families like inflation and crime in the
Border crisis but Biden's only
interested in appeasing his far left
base with a focus on abortion a student
debt bailout and has promised to save
democracy finds as delusional as ever
and he has a new attack line that just
rolls right off the tongue
poles have been all over the place
I think that we're going to see one more
shift back to our side the closing days
and let me tell you why I think that
we're starting to see some of the good
news on the economy the election is not
a referendum it's a choice it's a choice
and the Republican criticized my
economic record but look at what I've
inherited and what I've done and look at
what they're offering it's mega mega
trickle down
mega mega trickle down the kind of
policies that have failed the country
before and will fail it again mega mega
triple down and while Biden tests out a
last-ditch effort to sway voters it
looks like AOC has given up she's
straight up making fun of her
constituents at a town hall watch
all right all right listen all right
listen listen okay
[Applause]
[Music]
I think she has presidential material
written all over
it's confident this is this is
Fantasyland this is La La Land you've
got a president out there is telling
America that the economy is strong and
that uh we got a mayor who was telling
us the crime is all in our heads it's
just a perception everything is great
the economy is great he says the the
what did he say poor people middle class
people and even the rich people are
going to do great is just a matter of
time before it all happens look the
American people know what it costs to
buy gas to buy food they're very worried
they're worried about their heat I'm
worried about the heating bill okay
everybody's worried about it too
here's the bottom line the bottom line
is that you have to ask yourself it's
that age-old question are you better off
under under Joe Biden than you were two
years ago inflation was what 1.6 two
years ago now it's 8.3 the highest in 40
years now he says gas prices are coming
down well when Trump was President they
were two dollars and 30 cents now
they're down to four dollars from an
all-time high and you think we're doing
well I mean this is this is the time for
Americans to we'll talk about crime in
Katy spot but this is a time for
Americans to say enough do you think
this new mega mega triple down or
whatever it is do you do you think he
came up with that
I don't know uh it's good to be back
to uh I don't I don't I don't disagree
largely with with the way you frame the
frame the beginning of this and I think
judge you put some meat on the bones I
I'd probably be doing this a lot
differently I think there are things to
be bragging about and things to be
touting that they were able to get
accomplished over the last two years
this Congress and sometimes the
president's there sometimes he's not I
think if I were them you got to give him
a very tight message about
infrastructure about prescription drugs
about keeping taxes low tell them let
the American people know that the
Republicans have two plans or Rick Scott
plan and a plan that Kevin McCarthy has
put out that really has some differing
views and for that matter differing
priorities uh suggesting things that
people to your point judge know to not
necessarily be true everyone knows
you're paying more for eggs you're
paying more for gasoline you're paying
more for uh meat in the at the at the at
a restaurant or in the grocery store and
we know we're paying more for gas
they're probably things we could be
doing to reduce the price of a gallon of
gasoline that the White House could
probably do I'd do it
um because I think if you if you to your
point I I like to show Fantasy Island
but your idea about fantasy land and
some of the things are being talked
about some of it's incredulous and some
of it the the some of the things he's
done I think has been incredibly good
he's got to say those things if he does
not uh we can find ourselves at a real
disadvantage in the house and the Senate
uh come a couple weeks from now did you
see Joe at the podium with those three
people behind them yeah they looked uh
yeah he's been told to smile yeah they
looked a little worried about what's
coming in the future they've gone from
Ultra magascara to
mega mega trickle-down economics which
just brings up the contrast between the
economy under President Trump and the
economy now under Joe Biden and when it
comes to Americans not feeling like
they're focusing on the issues that
matter to their families they may be
focusing on them soon given the way the
generic ballot is going with a number of
polls Republicans are up by six points
in not just one poll but many polls this
week on the generic ballot it's not like
inflation is going to get fixed in the
next three weeks two and a half weeks
it's going to stay the same or get worse
as a result so things aren't going to
get better for Democrats on these issues
on the issues of inflation and crime the
way that Democrats and particularly the
White House have ignored this is is
really incredible considering how it
affects people inflation and crime are
issues of survival to a human being if
you can't afford to feed your family if
you can't afford to pay your mortgage if
you feel like every time you get on the
subway or you stop to put gas in your
car that your life is in danger as a
result whether you're in Philadelphia or
somewhere else as a result of crime
those are existential threats to your
well-being to your family and yet they
have acted like they're not even an
issue and then today the D.A of
Philadelphia is arguing that you are a
racist if you dare to criticize the
policies while ignoring the fact that
the majority of the people who are
victims of this are minorities in those
cities and so they've chosen to ignore
it they're still the top issues and Lee
zeldin is now ahead by one point in New
York as a result of focusing on these
things and I think that they've really
not done a good job of thinking about
what the American people want rather
than just focusing on trying to get
their base out for elections but how
fund as an AOC Town Hall look she does
Impressions she dances oh man but nobody
wants to listen AOC rallies are 25 to
get in 100 to get out
I can't listen to this idiot anymore uh
it's really hard to watch but the move
she's really doing is not the bot from
side to side her dance is the hustle
okay because she is hustled that entire
District No accomplishments to speak to
other than killing Amazon jobs crime has
spiked in response to her defund
narrative where she wanted to kill off
the police budget now everybody's
killing each other and that's what I'm
so fascinated by is the Democratic
indifference the people who help them
win elections are the people most
adversely affected by what they've done
to the country you're talking about
minorities being plagued by what crime
and inflation as a former cab driver I
can tell you nobody in my taxi garage
which is all minority like I was
literally they don't know my name I'm
referred to this day as the white guy
they called me the white guy for real
and they're great people but the point
is nobody leaves the taxi and goes home
to the inner city where they're worried
about about getting mugged on the way to
the bodega or the bogada as Joe Biden
calls it and cares about climate change
you dig so when they say like in
politics you got to read the room
Biden's not even in the room okay to be
clear he's getting sent home to Delaware
this weekend uh because they're tired of
trying to keep him on stage at the end
of his speech that's what those three
people are doing there they're the Biden
Wrangler so he doesn't wander off into
the audience because it's sad Joe Biden
is the only president in history who
takes more time to exit a speech than he
does to give one that poor band how many
times do they have to play hell to the
chief before he finds his way out you
did forget about the fact they do have a
migrant Tent City in aoc's District now
yeah that is a big accomplishment let's
not skip that she finally got somebody
housing
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else